- So the question is can
President Trump pardon
all of the people who
participated in the Capitol Riots
and laid siege to the Capitol?
Well, unfortunately, the answer to that
is almost certainly yes
if President Trump remains the President.
This is probably one
of the primary reasons
why it would be a good idea to impeach
and remove him before
he finishes out his term
to prevent this and other
all sorts of really terrible pardons.
While the Constitution
does say the President
can't pardon people in
terms of impeachment,
this probably is not what that clause
of the Constitution means.
So yeah, there's probably
nothing that would prevent
a sitting President Trump from
pardoning all the rioters.
Now, of course, that's for federal crimes,
but unfortunately, the President's
pardon power does extend
to District of Columbia crimes as well.
So stay tuned for more
legal election coverage,
and as always, I'll see you in court.